BORIS DEBIC: Welcome
everybody to one more Authors
at Google Talk.
Today with us are science
fiction authors Larry Niven
and Gregory Benford.
They have been here
about a year ago, when
they presented the
"Bowl of Heaven."
And today they will
talk about the sequel
to the "Bowl of
Heaven," "Shipstar."
I will try to make this
introduction short,
but it's hard to make
introductions short
when you have such amazing
people next to you.
LARRY NIVEN: You need
younger writers for that.
BORIS DEBIC: I need
younger writers, yes.
So, a little bit
about Larry Niven.
He was born in 1938 in
Los Angeles, California.
Won his first Hugo award
for the best short story
for the "Neutron Star" in 1967.
And he won it in 1972
for "Inconstant Moon,"
and in 1975 for "The Holeman."
In 1976 he won the Hugo
award for the best novelette,
"The Borderland of Sol."
He won the Nebula Award in
1970, and the Hugo and Locus
awards in 1971 for "Ringworld."
He is famous for this.
Niven has written scripts
for three science fiction
television series, and
Illogical Fantasy series.
He's also the author of
"Niven's Laws for Writers."
And we may get back to
them later during the talk.
Larry Niven attended Washburn
University in Topeka,
California Institute of
Technology, and UCLA.
He holds degrees in
mathematics and psychology.
Much of Larry's writing
since the 1970s has
been in collaboration
particularly
with Jerry Pournelle,
Steven Barnes,
Brenda Cooper, Edward
M. Lerner, and of course
our second guest,
Gregory Benford.
Gregory Benford was born in
1941 in Mobile, Alabama--
GREGORY BENFORD: Mobile.
BORIS DEBIC: Mobile.
Mobile, Alabama.
GREGORY BENFORD: It's not
mobile, it stays there.
BORIS DEBIC: In 1969, he began
writing a regular science
column for the magazine,
"Amazing Stories."
His time travel
novel, "Timescape"
won both the Nebula award, and
the John W. Campbell Memorial
Award.
Gregory has been nominated for
four Hugo awards and 12 Nebula
awards.
In addition to "Timescape,"
he and Gordon Eklund
won the Nebula for the novelette
"If the Stars are Gods."
Gregory has created and written
about the first computer
virus in the late '60s.
We can come back to this.
This is the right
environment for this.
GREGORY BENFORD: Yes.
BORIS DEBIC: His work in
physics at the University
of California,
Irvine has focused
on theoretical and
experimental plasma physics,
including studies of
extremely strong turbulence
in astrophysical
context, and studies
of magnetic structures from the
galactic center to large scale
galactic jets.
If you have read the
"Bowl of Heaven,"
you may pieced these two
pieces of information together.
He made a contribution in
understanding and addressing
global warming and
related chemical
changes in ocean water.
Gregory also serves on the board
of directors of the student
committee of the Mars Society,
which is dear to my heart.
And Gregory has received
a Bachelor of Science
in physics from the University
of Oklahoma in Norman,
followed by a Master of
Science and Doctorate
from the University of
California, San Diego.
That was the shortest
I could do it.
My apologies for all
the things that I missed
in this introduction,
but I think
it would take half an hour to
get them properly introduced.
Please give a warm
welcome to them.
GREGORY BENFORD: So, next slide.
Let me just start
with "Shipstar,"
and to tell you how
much disappointed
I was when I read
the "Bowl of Heaven."
The reason I was
disappointed was
that I did not realize that
it would have a sequel.
I devoured the book in a couple
of weeks, and I get to the end
and it says, to be continued.
I didn't like you
guys at that moment.
But I love the time that
we have "Shipstar" now.
So you want to start us off by--
LARRY NIVEN: Let me apologize
to him and about half of you.
Because I made every
effort to find an ending
for the "Bowl of Heaven,"
knowing that it was the middle
a two-part novel.
We always planned it
to be a two-part novel,
but I thought I could
find a break point.
All we really did was give our
characters a chance to sit down
and rest for a while.
GREGORY BENFORD: Yeah, which
they needed at that point.
And so did we.
We started this project thinking
we could do it in one volume.
And then it became
impossible because we
don't like door stop novels.
LARRY NIVEN: It
became impossible
because he kept finding
new implications.
GREGORY BENFORD: Oh yeah,
it's always me, isn't it?
No we just-- you
know, it's a big idea.
In fact, we're already
getting pressure
from people saying, hey, you've
got to go further, and tie up
this thing and then that thing.
And so forth.
And we might do it in an
anthology or something
like that.
I'm not sure.
But it's a big object.
And how many "Ring World"
novels are there now?
Five, isn't it?
LARRY NIVEN: No it's four.
GREGORY BENFORD: Four.
Seems like five.
LARRY NIVEN: Unless
you count "Protector."
GREGORY BENFORD: Well I do.
LARRY NIVEN: Because the
"Ringworld" did not appear.
GREGORY BENFORD: True.
So this is the
way you do things.
When you're trying to
figure out a big object,
as you saw from our
previous appearance here,
we went out and even
commissioned art,
so we could see what
the thing looked like.
And I'll review some
of that in the slides
here, and then show
you some new stuff
that we developed for the
book, the second book,
the "Shipstar."
LARRY NIVEN: Having
finished a book,
you keep on thinking about it.
It's always true.
GREGORY BENFORD: Right.
I mean, you can see why
Shakespeare killed everybody
at the end of Hamlet, because
at least there's no sequel.
It was already long.
This will be a quick review.
This is Ringworld,
ancient history now.
And next.
And then this is-- what is this?
Oh yeah, that's the-- right.
That's--
LARRY NIVEN: We're
going to have to keep
peering over our
shoulder, aren't we?
GREGORY BENFORD: Right.
The scale is solar
system, and so,
and we got all the visual
thinking about this
was done by Freeman Dyson,
about Dyson spheres.
And there is a program
at Link Observatory,
To look for Dyson's
spheres right now.
And the WISE experiment
is still being
mined, that was an infrared
scope FDL 2 point, which
is still being mined to look
for Dyson spheres, which
are tiny, fairly faint infrared
sources where there's no star.
LARRY NIVEN: It wouldn't be
that faint, though, would they?
it's still the output of a star.
GREGORY BENFORD: Yeah.
LARRY NIVEN: It's just
being reduced down
to the temperature
of warm water.
GREGORY BENFORD: Yeah right.
Next.
What is that?
And so these ideas about
building up structures--
this is one that came
around in the 1970s--
is that, how would you
build a Dyson sphere?
You'd build it out
of these belts, which
begin to look suspiciously
like Ringworlds.
And next.
And then you go on to
other formations like this.
This is not going to
be stable, but remember
this is on the scale
of the solar system.
And then next.
LARRY NIVEN: There we are.
GREGORY BENFORD: Oh this is
about the Link Observatory
program, which Geoff
Marcy is running
right now to look
for Dyson spheres.
Next.
And this is kind of the general
philosophy of the subject.
You see, there's a term in the
genre dubbed Big Dumb Objects.
So when I began
thinking about this,
and talked to Larry
about it, I always
objected to the dumb part.
Because the Ringworld is
actually not passively stable.
You have to readjust for
every time somebody slammed
their foot down
in the Ringworld.
It's inherently unstable.
It will slide sideways
right into the stars.
So you have to have corrector
jets the whole time.
So it's really not
that dumb an object.
Next.
LARRY NIVEN: It started dumb.
GREGORY BENFORD:
It started dumb.
LARRY NIVEN: And
the Big Dumb Object
is far easier to write about
if you're a storyteller.
BORIS DEBIC: It's probably
self-assembled as well, right?
LARRY NIVEN: The thing
isn't doing anything.
It's there to be explored.
All your action comes
from the characters
in a Big Dumb Objects story.
GREGORY BENFORD: There are
no maintenance chapters
in a Big Dumb Object story.
Next.
This is a view of the old ideas.
This is from the th O'Neill
colony era in the 1970s.
Certainly it looked
like you want
to live in space in a
stressed object, which
is spinning at the same time.
That's the point.
Everything we're
going to talk about
is under very, very
high tensile stress,
because it's like an
inverted swimming pool.
Right?
Next.
And so, Art C. Clark did this
in "Rendezvous with Rama,"
variable big long solar area
enters the solar system.
What's it doing here?
It's only just cruising
by and doing a delta-v.
It's on its way out already.
Next.
And so we devised this guy.
This is the size of
the solar system,
and that little bright
object in there is its star.
And the jet is propelling
the bowl of heaven forward.
So this is a habitat that's
moving through the galaxy.
So you get to stay
at home and go
for a nice long journey
on cruise control,
more or less, except
it's inherently unstable.
Right?
And if you turn the jet
off, the shell, the bowl,
falls into the star.
Big problem.
But of course, walking around
on two legs is unstable too.
It requires a command
and control system
which most animals don't have.
I mean, part of the whole
thing about human intelligence
is that we're on an
already unstable platform.
It's not like you're a
smart animal with four legs.
You've got only two.
So smart creatures will
make unstable structures.
That's kind of a lesson.
Next.
And this is how it
looks from the side.
The discovery moment is when the
starship halts just above this,
it can look back and see
that it's a bowl and a star.
Because from behind,
unless you notice the jet,
you can't even see the star.
So it's a big sudden revelation
when you overhaul it.
And that's the opening
of "Bowl of Heaven."
Next.
And this is the star,
a very troubled star,
which produces the jet,
which is on the other side.
And the entire star
is magnetically
manipulated to make the
jet, because it's not
a naturally occurring object.
Next.
Yeah.
And this is only
part of the diagram,
but it shows you
that the object is
spinning to give
centrifugal gravity.
And it depends on where
you are in the bowl,
I'll show you the acceleration
plots a little later.
The point is, you're up near
the axis, there's no gravity.
There's no centrifugal
gravity to match anything.
Down here on the Great Plain,
you get about-- what is it?
0.8 earth scrap.
So it's not exactly hours,
it's a little bit lighter.
And the beings who
live there are bigger,
as you would expect.
It turns out the first ones
you meet are giant birds.
Smart birds.
So all this goes
into the design.
Next.
This is the view from the Great
Plain, looking at the star.
By the way, the star is
moved into the field of view.
Don Davis had the
dimensions wrong,
but I like this shot, because
it shows you the star too.
But that's actually
further to the right.
So this is what it
looks like if you
stand on the Great Plain
looking up into the sky.
This is a very, very clear day.
But on a clear day you can see
across the entire structure.
And you're aware of
the fact that you
live in a non-planetary
environment.
Next.
So this, by the way, is the
acceleration as you can read.
It's the centrifugal
gravity versus angle.
And there's no
gravity when you're
close to the axis,
which is called,
by the way, the knothole.
And that's how we
fly into this object.
And gravity's maximum
out on the Great Plain.
But notice that it's
curved, locally curved.
And therefore there's an
acceleration of gravity,
next, parallel to
the ground also.
And as you get near the
axis, it's pushing you away.
And it was designed
that way because they
don't want the inhabitants
to go near the axis,
because that's where
all the magic occurs.
And you have to steer the
jet through the knothole.
And that's where
the elite lives.
It's like Manhattan.
You don't want people coming.
And so there's a
push against people
who are trying to walk
their way to the axis.
Which is, remember, on the
scale of 100 billion kilometers
away, so it's going
to take a while.
So almost all the
transport of this thing
is, we learn in both novels,
is by very fast maglev trains.
Because they don't
have any fossil fuels.
Right?
You can't fly around in the
air burning high value fossil
fuels.
So you use trains,
but not entirely.
Next.
This is what it
looks like as you're
zooming around far about.
There's, by the way, a confined
atmosphere with a thin mono
layer to keep all this stuff in.
But on the right there
are these enormous storms.
There are always storms
out on the great seas.
But on the left,
those are the mirrors
that reflect sunlight back
to the base of the jet,
and create the
energy for the jet.
And then that's
magnetically shaped
into a jet that blows
through the knothole.
So you see, it's propelling
itself using the energy
from the star in
more ways than one.
It reflects the
sunlight back, and then
the sub blows the
plasma off, and that
pushes the whole contraption
through the galaxy.
Next.
And this is the
view of the clouds
as you descend toward the top
of the layered atmosphere.
You can see some light
effects, and refraction,
and spectral
break-up, and so on.
It's kind of a pretty view.
Of course, this
isn't painted, this
is actually a view of
a cloud on the earth.
Giving away a secret here.
This is not actually
from another planet,
it's from this planet.
Next.
And this is how they got in.
This is the frontispiece on
"Bowl of Heaven" in full color.
This is how the Starship
flies into the knothole,
against the jet, to
get into the object.
They figure it's the closest
and it's the safest approach.
Rather than flying up in
front of somebody in the sky,
you come at them from behind.
So they loop around the bowl
and come up against the jet,
swimming upstream.
Next.
And this is-- ah good.
And this is close up
of the foreground.
Notice way over on
the left, there's
some human beings
walking around,
trying to figure out
how this thing works.
Over here is what is
called zigzag tree.
A local common formation
of a kind of tree.
Which--
LARRY NIVEN: We
didn't describe that.
Don Davis, the
artist, interpreted
our minor description.
GREGORY BENFORD: Right.
Notice that it secures
itself against high winds
by having roots come
out of the limbs.
So it's really pinned down,
and therefore lasts longer.
And then over here,
there's this funny thing
which you'll see up close, which
is another method of transport
on the bowl.
Next.
It is an enormous
living dirigible,
which makes its
own hydrogen, which
is by the way a
convenient weapon.
And it's called a
skyfish, unoriginally.
And there's a whole lot of
this in both books, what
it's like to be in the skyfish
and to fight a skyfish.
GREGORY BENFORD: We do have some
neat life forms in these books.
LARRY NIVEN: Yeah.
That was the point.
Strange interesting aliens.
So we spent a lot of time
just dreaming up new aliens.
BORIS DEBIC: And social order.
GREGORY BENFORD: And
the social order, right.
And this is where the
skyfish moors itself.
Again, this isn't
a painting, this
is actually a prominent
mountain on the planet.
Anybody know what it is?
Notice it looks just like
it has a base on the top.
BORIS DEBIC: Kilimanjaro.
GREGORY BENFORD:
Yes, you're right.
You're cheating.
Yes, Kilimanjaro.
This is how Kilimanjaro
actually looks.
It's an extinct volcano
in the middle of Africa.
Very close to the equator too.
Next.
And so this is some comment
on-- these kinds of structures
are inherently
conservative, right?
Because it's too easy
to make a mistake.
And so there are lots of
rules-- you can read this,
I won't read it
to you-- that say,
no sudden movements,
basically, is the order.
And you have to have
a good clear hierarchy
so things don't get out
of control, literally.
You're living in an
inherently unstable system.
You see?
We live on-- the Earth is
actually a Big Dumb Object.
LARRY NIVEN: Not quite so dumb
as we would like to believe.
We used to think that continents
don't move, for instance.
Drifting continents
is a newish concept.
The more we learn
about the Earth,
the more we become tempted
to try to do things about it.
Weather control.
GREGORY BENFORD: Which
is certainly coming,
or climate control, actually.
LARRY NIVEN: Yeah.
GREGORY BENFORD:
Geo-engineering, as it's known.
LARRY NIVEN: Yeah, weather
control is probably impossible.
GREGORY BENFORD: Right.
Right.
There'll be an app
for it eventually.
Next.
BORIS DEBIC: Big bust events.
GREGORY BENFORD: Yeah, exactly.
Smart means vigilant.
So as I said here, I used
to work on shrimp boats
on the Gulf of Mexico.
I'm from southern Alabama.
And a boat, as my grandfather
remarked to me once,
is just looking for
a chance to sink.
Something's always
got to go wrong.
And it does in, particularly in
the second novel, "Shipstar."
Next.
LARRY NIVEN: You
wouldn't respect us
if things didn't go wrong.
GREGORY BENFORD: Right.
Yes.
So this is the thing.
Whoops!
I mean, if you drill
through the bowl,
in some places it's only a few
millimeters thick, than what's
on the outside?
High vacuum, and you are
spinning with respect
to the surroundings, at
thousands of kilometers
a second.
So it's a great way
to launch spacecraft.
You can just pitch them off
the back porch, so to speak.
And they have a
very high velocity.
And that's how you explore
planets as you go by them,
or solar systems as you come by.
You don't want to get too
close to the solar system,
because this object will disturb
the orbits in a close flyby.
So you stay well out, and
you throw these craft out
at thousands of kilometers a
second, and they go exploring,
and they come back.
That's it, OK good.
That's the end of
the show and tell.
So, we end up with-- the
strategy of the books
is, we introduced
you to this place.
The humans in the
drama make a number
of assumptions,
so do the readers.
And we deliberately didn't talk
about certain aspects of it,
so that in the second book,
we didn't pull the rug out
from under your assumptions.
And what seemed to be true
turns out to be not true.
And the tales about how
the whole system works
reveal who actually
manages the place.
When you walk into
Google, you don't
meet Sergey Brin when
you're signing in.
Well, when you come onto
an object like this,
the people who intercept
you when you're
trying to board--
after all, you're
boarding a ship-- are
not the captain, or even
the same species as the captain.
So there's a real
hierarchy, and you
have to understand it if you're
going to live in this society.
LARRY NIVEN: Remember guys,
this is an old object.
We made it 100 million years
old, or something like it.
They've been accepting
boarders, expecting boarders,
for nearly that long.
GREGORY BENFORD: Yeah.
LARRY NIVEN: They know
what to do about visitors.
Even armed visitors.
GREGORY BENFORD: Yeah.
And they have some
interesting weapons too.
But on the ground, the
weapons are very constrained
because you can't
make a weapon that's
big enough to blow a
hole in the structure.
That's a very bad idea.
LARRY NIVEN: Yes.
BORIS DEBIC: It's a
very fragile world.
LARRY NIVEN: Yes.
BORIS DEBIC: Going
back to writing.
So "Niven's Laws for Writers."
Larry, how did you come
up with these laws?
LARRY NIVEN: I
wrote Niven's Laws
because I'd come
up with a few, what
I considered to be basic truths.
They're not all for
writers, just a few of them.
Never fire a laser at a mirror.
From a 1964 Democratic
Convention in Chicago,
I got never throw
shit at an armed man.
And never stand
next to somebody who
is throwing shit
at an armed man.
But one of my own principles,
never let a waiter escape.
Your waiter is
holding you prisoner,
whether he realizes
it or not, and he
doesn't have to come back.
BORIS DEBIC: In the
ones for writers
though, you have
one that says, it
is a sin to waste
the reader's time.
LARRY NIVEN: Yes.
Cutting your manuscript
is always a good idea.
You gradually-- ha ha!
Bob Weison taught me this.
And he taught me and
Jerry Pournelle too.
We cut the bejesus out
of "Emoting God's Eye,"
Jerry and I, with Bob's help.
We come to "Lucifer's
Hammer," and we've
turned it in at 250,000 words.
Bob, the editor, looks
at this and then thinks,
we can't raise the
price high enough,
we won't sell any copies.
We have to split this in two.
Everybody looked at Hammer and
found no place for it to split.
So Bob looks at "Lucifer's
Hammer," with intent to cut it,
and he couldn't spare a word.
We'd already done our cutting
according to all his tenets.
Eventually they raised the
price to something unreasonable,
and you guys all paid it.
GREGORY BENFORD: That
was when I realized
that there should
be software called,
for example, Anti-adjective.
You take a given text,
it goes through it,
takes out all the adjectives.
Right?
And then the obvious second
product is Anti-adverb.
LARRY NIVEN: I remember
a story in which
it was sort of a
magical salt shaker.
You'd hold it like that, and
the adjectives would all go.
You want it in a
woman's magazine,
you hold it like this, and
the adjectives all come back.
GREGORY BENFORD: Right.
Right.
Well, if you're a
romance novelist,
you just write the bare text,
and then Adjective Adder
comes in and makes the
right selections for you.
And Adverb Adder, saves all
that typing, and thinking.
Because it's a romance novel.
LARRY NIVEN: What else
did I say about writers?
BORIS DEBIC: What else
did you say about writers.
Writers who write for other
writers should write letters.
Never be embarrassed or
ashamed about anything
you choose to write.
Think of this before
you send it to market.
Stories to end all
stories in a given topic.
Don't.
If you have nothing to say,
say it anyway you like.
Stylistic innovations,
contorted story lines, or none,
exotic or genderless pronouns,
internal inconsistencies,
the recipe for preparing your
lover as a cannibal banquet,
feel free.
If what you have to say
is important and difficult
to follow, use the
simplest language possible.
If the reader doesn't get it
then, let it not be your fault.
GREGORY BENFORD: Yeah.
That's a very good rule.
There's another one that
I kind of feel about,
and that is that you should
not use unreliable narrators
in science fiction,
because it's already
straining credulity
of most of the public.
But if you want to have the
point-of-view character lying
to the reader, you're
really taking huge risks.
I mean, the first
time you find out
that the narrative voice
tells you something
that it knew was a lie,
there's a powerful tendency
to throw it against the wall
and see if the spine will crack.
And if you're strong
enough, it will.
BORIS DEBIC: And last rule,
everybody talks first draft.
LARRY NIVEN: Yeah.
What you're hearing
here, if it gets quoted,
it'll embarrass us
the rest of our lives.
Keep that in mind.
GREGORY BENFORD: Yeah, life
is lived in first draft.
BORIS DEBIC: Why
don't we open it up
for some questions
from the audience?
AUDIENCE: Basically, so
science fiction often
results, as the books you
were just talking about do,
around introducing
new technologies,
and seeing how the people in the
societies interact with that.
Something that I think a
lot of people at Google
might find interesting, but a
lot of people don't know about,
and if you're comfortable
talking about it,
is SIGMA, the group where
you guys were proposing
interesting ideas and thoughts,
as a bit of a think tank.
Are there any
interesting stories
you can share about
that, or thoughts you
have on that group, and the
things that came out of it?
GREGORY BENFORD:
It's about SIGMA,
which is a group
of SF writers who
will think for spare change.
And we advise people, like
Department of Defense.
LARRY NIVEN: Yeah, there
are science fiction writers
who won't work with
the government,
because that's their attitude.
There are some who will.
And a lot of us
have joined SIGMA.
SIGMA will work with anybody,
will work with the government.
They don't work with terrorists.
GREGORY BENFORD: Yes.
And we named it that because
you know, in mathematics,
sigma stands for sum.
We sum it up.
People who want you
to think forward
on a scale of say,
10 years, 20 years.
It's what we're used to doing in
bureaucracies, largely or not.
And it leads to many
interesting interactions.
I'll never forget-- you were
there, I think, at this.
At one of the CIA
hotels in the DC area,
we had a sealed room,
electronically isolated.
Because it was a bunch
of classified stuff.
And the FBI and the
CIA were present,
and I'd never realized
until that moment
how much they hated each other.
I mean the room was
alive with tension.
And I'm glad nobody
could communicate out,
because it was
disturbing, really, to see
how they contested everything.
That's one of the things
they didn't mean to reveal,
but we picked up
on it right away.
LARRY NIVEN: And I never
noticed any of that.
I got some blind spots.
GREGORY BENFORD: Yeah.
You learn some things
from this interaction,
particularly that
the government really
does not take long
views of some subjects,
because it's hard to do.
You know this at Google, you're
thinking long on all kinds
of axes that other people don't.
And that's why they
call in consultants
who they can believe or not.
AUDIENCE: As you're working
through this project,
do you have any other ideas
in the back of your mind
that you'd be interested in
exploring with future stories?
LARRY NIVEN: Not then.
Whatever we had, we use.
It took us about three
years once we got going,
but we had several
years ahead of that
to play with these notions.
Whatever came up,
we worked it in.
But since we
published the books,
since we turned in "Shipstar,"
we've been thinking.
There are avenues available,
and we don't want to write them.
We want to persuade other
people to write them.
We'd like to put
together an anthology
of "Shipstar" stories,
"Bowl of Heaven" stories.
GREGORY BENFORD: There are a
lot of things we left unexplored
just because there's
so many implications.
For example, who's sending
the gravitational waves
which apparently have
messages in them,
from the target star,
which we call Glory?
I mean, what's that about?
We actually don't deal with
that a lot in the book,
and so it's an open door.
People can walk through it.
But there are many other
things that are puzzles.
Like, how do all these
species interact?
There are a lot of
intelligent alien species,
and they tend to be
specialized in what they do.
So how does that society work?
What was the basic idea of
the "Bowl of Heaven" anyway?
To build an enormous
contraption and then sail around
the galaxy.
It's like an
enormous cruise ship.
But who thinks on a time
scale of millions of years?
I mean, in a way, it's a way
of thinking about ourselves.
Because this society,
this civilization
is 10,000 or so years old.
What happens when you're
millions of years old?
What kind of structure
does that require, in order
to not collapse and dissolve,
as so many of our civilizations
have?
And so, what about
a galaxy, which
has been around a long
time, 10 billion years.
And we're the latest arrivals.
Most of the stars in the
galaxy are older than we are.
What kind of society does
it take to last a long time?
Because we should
think about that,
because we got the same problem.
LARRY NIVEN: As
slow as the Bowl is,
it has not explored
very much of the galaxy.
We are likely to find faster,
older aliens somewhere out
there.
GREGORY BENFORD: Yeah.
LARRY NIVEN: We'll toss that
into the list of questions
available to other authors.
GREGORY BENFORD:
And that comes up
in "Shipstar," that there
are other such societies.
And they're cruising around too.
They may not be built this
way, but they're there
to exchange really long term
information, about what's
going on in the galaxy,
about possible problems,
or newly emergent species
that have to be dealt with,
things like that.
LARRY NIVEN: Greg
and I have both
been working with alien
communications and aliens
for a long time.
Greg's got a library buildup
of aliens who can't travel,
but who can send information.
I've got the Dracula
tavern, which
is aliens gathering on Earth,
in slower than light ships.
GREGORY BENFORD: Pardon, what?
AUDIENCE: The galaxy itself
is a Big Dumb Object.
GREGORY BENFORD: Well the
galaxy is a Big Dumb Object.
Yeah.
LARRY NIVEN: Yeah,
OK I'll buy that.
GREGORY BENFORD: I
mean bad things happen.
Supernovae go off, destroy
whole civilizations.
Yeah.
LARRY NIVEN: In hundreds
of billions of years,
we may find that Big Dumb
Object is an artifact.
The galaxy's been reshaped.
It'll probably
still be ship stable
because you don't want
to ship it unstable.
AUDIENCE: So Mr.
Niven, I grew up
loving and devouring your books.
And you've both been
writing for quite awhile.
And over that time,
technology has advanced a lot.
But you're writing about things
that are so far in the future,
that today's differences
in technology
don't make much difference.
I'm curious how you feel your
writing process is different
now that there's
so much advances
in technology we know about.
LARRY NIVEN: I've
been using one rule.
Actually, I've been
using a lot of rules.
Here's one for free.
You look at what humankind
or any intelligent being
will want and need, and you try
to guess what it'll look like.
There are ultimates.
You want instant communication.
You probably can't
exceed light speed,
but instant communication,
we've already got.
We want instant learning.
That's a tough one.
It's got some drawbacks.
That we can play with.
We've always wanted
to drive faster.
The better your
vehicle is, the quicker
you can get to
where you're going.
Try to guess what the
ultimates will be,
and you've got a story.
BORIS DEBIC: That's the
advice of technology.
But what, for example, of
the speeding up of evolution?
And how do you
speed up evolution
if you-- let's say your
cortex material grows up
in complexity?
Can you do that?
Or are there different paths
of evolution in 10 million
or billions of
years in the future?
GREGORY BENFORD: Well remember,
we got this astonishingly smart
cerebral cortex for some
kind of evolutionary reason,
and many biologists
are rather puzzled
by why we're so
good at things that
don't seem to have
any real application
way back there in
the plains of Africa.
And it is kind of mysterious.
I mean, it's hard to believe
that all of mathematics
was opened up by our ability
to essentially understand
plane geometry and the
trajectory of thrown spears.
It's a big leap from
saying, well you know,
I want to hit this thing.
Once upon a time,
there was a primate
that threw a rock after
something it wanted to kill.
And it saw it as a kind
of a complicated process.
Those genes aren't
with us anymore.
The primate that said, hey
that's a beautiful parabola.
We got those genes.
So we got some
kind of selection,
and that's what leads to the
aesthetic sense of mathematics.
Dirac, who invented the electron
positron idea, and all that.
Great mathematical
physicist, said that,
to be a convincing
physical law, it
must be capable of
beautiful expression.
And if it's beautiful,
it will be true.
And he was a guided by that.
I asked him, if it
really was important.
And he said, yeah of course.
I mean what other
guide do we have?
There are many choices.
But choose the beautiful.
That's deeply embedded
in the genome.
And it got that way by something
that happened a long time ago.
And it's still at work.
I mean, the species is still
getting lots better at things.
And it is kind of a puzzle,
why we're so good at this.
And yet we can't communicate
with the dolphins and whales
very well.
LARRY NIVEN: I would
go with machines.
The next stages of
evolution, we'll
be building machines to do
our thinking for us better.
I can't see that our brains
are going to get much better.
There's no room in there.
No room in the skull.
No room in a woman's womb.
I see no end to being
able to build machines
to do our thinking for us, and
help us with our own thinking.
We may wind up as a combination
of human and machine.
We may wind up with
just the machine.
Stories point in all directions.
GREGORY BENFORD: Yeah.
Yeah, that's true.
Machine intelligence.
But remember, when they did
the autopsy on Einstein,
and preserved his
brain by the way,
they found that the brain
had enormous corrugation
in the cerebral cortex,
much more than most people.
And that's related somehow to
the complexity of the wiring
diagram.
So that's the way
we've been proceeding.
We're not getting
bigger brains, but we're
getting better somehow.
The only way to really increase
intelligence in a species
is to-- and speedily--
is to do it artificially.
But we're doing
that all the time.
There was a study
of the children
of the people in the New
Mexico town of Los Alamos that
found first, that indeed, about
50 percent of intelligence
is inheritable.
I'm an identical twin,
and the other part
of the research that shows that
is also from identical twins.
The trick is to see
that, so far there's
this reversion to the mean.
You got two really
smart parents,
the average intelligence
of their children
will be closer to the
lower intelligent parent
than to the upper.
There's a return to the mean.
But that emerges from the fact
that it's a complex property,
and you change some things,
and for the most part
it'll help you.
But there's always this
convergent toward the average,
because it's a complex system.
Nonetheless, you can still
get a lot of smart people
in places like say, Palo Alto.
Or Mountain View.
Flattering a local crowd.
LARRY NIVEN: You guys didn't
happen here by accident,
you were gathered.
GREGORY BENFORD: Yeah.
LARRY NIVEN: You can fight the
odds by intelligent design.
GREGORY BENFORD: Right.
Social selection.
So you're going
to mate together,
with foreseeable consequences.
And that's how you get
differences in society,
is the simple self selection
of courtship, for example.
So you put a lot of
smart people in a room,
you're going to get
some smart descendants.
And so now you understand
the secret purpose of Google.
That's right.
It's all about
just getting laid.
AUDIENCE: But one thing always
bothered me a little bit.
And it was, I think in "The
Ringworld" and other stories,
these productive
lotteries, in which
you suggest the human race
was breeding for luck.
And that seemed a rather
unscientific concept to me.
So I was wondering how
you justify mixing it
with strongly
scientific concepts.
LARRY NIVEN: You
had to be there.
That is, if you're my age,
then during the Golden Age,
you were reading stories
about psychic powers.
"Analog" was full of stories
about psychic powers,
probably because
Campbell was a believer.
Campbell the editor.
I had been inundated with
stories of psychic powers.
I read a few myself, trying
to use the assumptions
for hard fantasy stories.
Gil the Arm, for instance,
with his imaginary arm
that's TK and ESP, but
limited by his imagination.
Then I finally got to thinking
that the ultimate psychic power
would be pure author control.
Teela Brown is pure
author control.
I called it luck.
To Louie Wu, of
course, it is luck.
But you know the difference.
And as soon as I
was able to expose
that that was what was going
on, I got her off stage fast.
GREGORY BENFORD: Yeah.
Right.
Actually there's
maybe a new rule here.
Something like, if you
don't know how it works,
it always looks like magic.
As soon as you explain
it, it ceases to be.
LARRY NIVEN: Yes.
So I've blown the
whole thing for you.
Sorry about that.
GREGORY BENFORD: Well it kind
of intersects Clark's law.
Any sufficiently advanced
technology looks like magic.
I did a reversal
of that by the way,
when I was visiting
Arthur in Sri Lanka.
And it says, any technology
that does not appear magical
is insufficiently advanced.
Actually that could be the
motto of Google, really.
AUDIENCE: So as
science fiction authors
who've been writing
for a long time,
you've seen some of the
assumptions of your stories
broken, either by scientific
discoveries or MIT physics
students.
So has that affected
how you write?
GREGORY BENFORD:
Things have changed
in physics and other sciences.
And so some of our stories may
be obsolete now, or mistaken.
So has that changed
the way we write?
No.
Because we're actually
not any better
at predicting the
future than most people.
But--
LARRY NIVEN: After all, we
took this chance deliberately.
When we decided to write science
fiction rather than fantasy,
when we decided to
predict a future,
we knew we could be
obsolete rapidly.
The fastest a story of
mine ever became obsolete
was my first one.
Where they looked
into Mercury and found
that it wasn't geosynchronous.
It was spinning one and a half
times as fast as its year.
BORIS DEBIC: [INAUDIBLE]
LARRY NIVEN: Nearly the fastest
was "Lucifer's Hammer," where
you're looking at a 1975
future in which the Earth gets
hit with a comet, and a big one.
We knew that was
going to be obsolete.
We hoped we were writing a best
seller that would sell hundreds
of millions of copies
before it became obsolete.
GREGORY BENFORD: Yeah,
and before the comet hits.
LARRY NIVEN: It is just amazing
how well "Lucifer's Hammer"
is selling now, given
it's 40 years in the past.
GREGORY BENFORD: Yes.
LARRY NIVEN: It's a
historical disaster novel.
AUDIENCE: So a lot
of us here actually
end up having to write
those maintenance chapters.
Any advice on those pieces
that you skipped out on?
How should we be-- we're kind
of trying to take smart objects
and make them look
dumb to people,
so they can have the fun
parts of it happen to them.
How do we go about
maintaining these?
Have you thought of fun
failure cases of like,
it's invisible to the
people in the environment,
but the designers
probably have to deal
with this whole
other mess of stuff.
What do we do?
GREGORY BENFORD:
You know, stories
are about people under stress.
People who don't
have any problems
don't get written about.
Because they're boring.
LARRY NIVEN: Yeah.
GREGORY BENFORD:
So the clue to how
to construct a narrative
about some technological idea,
or a new invention,
or change in society
is to say, who does this hurt?
Who's going to be
worried by this,
or bothered, or defeated by it?
That person should be
the center of your story,
and then this person has
to understand the problem
and get through it.
That gives you the plot arc.
I learned that long
ago from James Blish,
as a matter of
fact, who said, look
for the person who
has the most at risk.
And that'll take you right
to the center of the story.
And from my point
of view, your goal
should always be to
write a sentence that
makes it impossible to not
read the next sentence.
Put that sentence first.
Try to make it work all the
way through a paragraph.
If you can get a reader
to read a whole paragraph,
and still want to read
the second paragraph,
then you're on your way.
And the reader will give
up the voyage to you
and then you're in charge.
But you've got to
hook them first.
And the hook had
better be sharp.
LARRY NIVEN: This matter of the
protagonist being the one who
gets hurt, I learned if
from Theodore Sturgeon,
and I used it to
write "Flash Crowd."
I had lists.
One, what do I expect to be
the result of teleportation
being invented about now.
And two, who gets hurt?
GREGORY BENFORD: Yeah.
LARRY NIVEN: And
it was all either
Jerryberry Jansen, or his
father, who guessed wrong
and lost it all on
the stock exchanges.
GREGORY BENFORD:
Yeah, and that's
a very good example
of a prediction,
because Larry wrote that
about teleportation,
and invented technology.
But what the era of
cell phones has done,
is to allow people say
in China, particularly,
to create flash crowds.
Everybody agrees they're going
to be there, they show up,
they do a protest, they
disperse, they're gone.
Didn't take teleportation,
it took cell phones.
But the flash crowd is a
known political phenomena
everywhere now.
But it's particularly being
used by revolutionary groups.
It was a big role
in the Arab Spring.
And it was all there
in a science fiction
story all along.
LARRY NIVEN: Cleverly disguised.
GREGORY BENFORD: Yes.
AUDIENCE: The older
I get, the more I
tend to reflect on how the
world has changed around me,
and how I feel
about those changes.
As people who imagine
what technology
will look like in
the future, I'm
curious if you have any
thoughts about how technology
has evolved over your career,
whether you're disappointed,
inspired, bored, and how humans
interact with technology.
LARRY NIVEN: Every so often
I find myself saying, welcome
to the future.
Every so often, it just
hits me in the face.
Things didn't used
to be this way.
GREGORY BENFORD: Yeah.
You know the most qualitative
thing I could speak on
is, that when I was growing up,
and having my gee whiz moments,
it was about space
travel and transport.
And that was sort of the
theme of science fiction
in the first half
of the 20th century.
But in the second half,
it's been about information,
more and more.
Your industry.
We've kind of reached
the limit on how fast you
can go in the atmosphere,
for awhile anyway.
But the flight of information
is speed of light.
And so it's hard to get
the feel of a phase shift
in technologies, from analog
to digital, for example.
And from hardware to software.
And so you always wonder what's
going to be the next thing.
And I actually published a cover
story in the magazine "Reason"
in 1997 called, "The
Biological Century" saying
the biggest motivating
stuff that's
going to make the world look
different in the 21st century
is going to come from
biology, not physics.
And it's going to be biological
engineering of the kinds that
are kind of hard to anticipate.
I expect they will
mostly center around
human reproduction at first.
I mean, what are the boundaries
on designer children,
for example.
I was at a conference
just recently
at Arizona State University
about what the century's going
to look like, and I said
there's an argument about,
should you be able to select
for blue eyes, or blond hair,
or something like that?
Well maybe.
But what about the
editing out of qualities?
I mean, there's a bell
curve in intelligence.
And everybody talks about,
let's make smarter people.
Let's work on the upper
end of the bell curve.
What about the lower end?
Do you want to edit
out the people who
were born with very,
very low intelligence?
Because they-- we know from
research they typically
don't have particularly
happy lives.
Do you want to edit them out?
Do you want to tinker with the
bell curve on the other side?
That's an interesting question.
I don't have a belief about it.
But it's going to
come up, because we're
going to figure some things out.
LARRY NIVEN: Making
the dumb humans smarter
might be easier than making
the smart ones smarter.
GREGORY BENFORD: Yeah.
LARRY NIVEN: We
could change the vote
in this country
within a generation
if every voter would
do his homework.
I do not know what
the result would be.
People who make this
prediction are generally wrong.
BORIS DEBIC: Making people
smarter is what good books do.
Let me just remind the audience.
GREGORY BENFORD:
That could be true.
You know, as far as
voters go, isn't it easier
to persuade your
enemies to not vote?
LARRY NIVEN: Yeah.
GREGORY BENFORD: Yeah,
give them something else
to do like, say,
"Game of Thrones."
Well that was catty,
because Railroad Martin's
an old friend of
ours, but still.
BORIS DEBIC: Let me get back
to the book a little bit.
So, as I said earlier, this is
the sequel to "Bowl of Heaven."
And if you think that
science fiction is looking
for life on Mars,
or on Europa, you
may be wrong, because
this is science fiction.
This is millions of
years into the future.
And really strange
possibilities so to speak.
So going back to "Shipstar,"
which I haven't read yet,
can you tell me what are
the few points that you're
really proud of
exploring in the sequel?
LARRY NIVEN: They weren't
my-- well, they were.
The coal mines that
came from the comets,
you're going to find them living
on the backside of the Bowl.
Greg put them there.
I have explored helium
2-flavored aliens
since a long time ago.
Greg came up exactly
with the plasma creatures
living in the sun itself.
Guiding the flare.
I'm reluctant to keep
exposing secrets to you,
but in fact, I think
you'll enjoy the book even
if you see something coming.
GREGORY BENFORD:
Yeah, one hopes.
I mean, part of this
whole strategy was to say,
here's this object, right?
You can see all this,
and you can see that.
But lots of it is not explained.
And so we just let it sit there.
I mean, and the slide's showing
you the whole configuration.
There are all kinds
of puzzles there.
But most people would look
at it and sort of accept it.
But our job was to try to
figure out how it worked.
Post facto, as a matter of fact.
I mean, we didn't have these
ideas when we started out.
We just invented them as
ways to make it plausible.
Like, hey, half the surface area
of the bowl is on the outside.
What are you going
to do with it?
BORIS DEBIC: Well
with that, I would
like to thank our guests today.
Larry Niven and Gregory Benford.
Please give them a hand.
[APPLAUSE]